[Music]
alhamdulillah
my respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of you
it's a pleasure and honor for me that
for the three consecutive sessions in
the peace exhibition the vision of Islam
I have been asked to give the concluding
speech the topic of this evening talk
is the concept of God in world's major
religions religion according to the
Oxford dictionary means a belief in a
super human controlling
power especially a personal God or gods
that deserve worship and
obedience in short according to loxford
dictionary religion means the belief in
God I start my talk by quoting a verse
from glorious Quran from Surah al- Imran
chapter number three verse number 64
which
says say oh people of the book
come to Common terms as between us and
you which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and patrons other than
Allah if they turn
back
witness that we are Muslims bowing a
will to Allah subhana tala this verse of
the Glorious Quran according to me I
call it the master key for da whenever
we speak to different types of people
people of different religions the Quran
says come to Common terms as between us
and
you though the verse Begins by
saying say oh people of the book this
verse can be used for people of all
religions it specifically refers to the
Jews and Christians but in general it
can refer to the people of all religions
and the first term is Allah that we
worship none but Allah subhana tala
almighty God one thing common
alhamdulillah in all the world's major
religions
is that the followers of any religion
they believe that the god they worship
ship is the same for themselves as well
as for others for example the god with
the Hindus worship they believe he's the
God for the Hindus as well as for the
non
Hindus the god with the Christian
worship they believe he's the same God
for the Christians as well as
non-christians and the god which we
Muslims
believe we believe that Allah subhana wa
tala almighty God is the same God for
the Muslims as well as for the
non-muslims the world's major religions
can be broadly classified and divided
into Semitic religions and the
non-semitic
religions the Semitic religions are
those religions which are followed by
The
semites Who are the semites the semites
are the descendants of
Shem and it's mentioned in the
Bible in the Old Testament in the Book
of Genesis chapter number 5-1 Shem is
mentioned there and he is the son of
prophet Noah alisam peace be upon him so
Semitic religions are those religions
which are followed by the semites the
descendants of Shem the
Jews the Arabs the Assyrians the fans
who speak the language Hebrew Arabic
aramic fitions Etc the major among the
Semitic religions are Judaism
Christianity and
Islam the non-semitic religions can be
further divided into Arian religions and
the non- Arian
religions the Arian religions are those
religions which are followed by the
Arians a powerful group of indoeuropean
speaking people who originated from Iran
and Northern India in the first half of
of the second Millennium that's 2,00 to
1,500
BC the Arian religions can be further
divided into Vic religion and the non-vc
religions the Vic religion is that
religion in which the people follow The
Vedas
and it's today called as a Moma as
Hinduism or
brahmanism but the right word should be
Vian
the non-ic
religions are those IR in religions
which do not follow the vas like sism
jism Etc and Zoran ISM also happens to
be an Aran religion which is not
associated with
Hinduism the non- Arian religions they
are divided depending upon the origin
for example those that originated from
China like
confessionalism like taism those that
originated from
Japan like Shintoism Etc but most of
these nonar religions they do not have a
concept of God and they are more often
referred to as ethical
systems that is the reason as far as my
talk today is concerned the concept of
God in world's major religions I will be
discussing about RN religions and the
Semitic
religions before we discuss the concept
of God in any religion first I'd like to
make one point clear that the best and
the most authentic way and methodology
of understanding any religion is to try
and understand what the scripture of
that religion has to speak about
almighty
God trying to understand the concept of
God by observing the followers of that
religion may not be correct because many
of times the followers of that religion
themselves do not know what is the
correct concept of God that's the reason
the best the most authentic methodology
to understand the concept of God in a
religion is to try understand what the
sacred scripture of that religion has to
speak about
God the most famous among the Aran
religions is The Vic religion that is
called as
Hinduism first we'll discuss the concept
of God in Hinduism
when we ask any Hindu that how many gods
does he believe in some will say three
some will say 10 some will say thousand
While others may say 33 crores 330
million but when we ask a learned Hindu
who is well vered with his Hindu
scriptures he will tell you that Hindus
should actually believe and worship only
one God but the common
Hindu he believes in a philosophy known
as
pantheism the common Hindu believes that
everything is God the tree is God the
sun is God the Moon is God the human
being is God the snake is called what we
Muslims believe is everything is God's g
o d with an apostrophe is everything
belongs to God the tree belongs to God
the sun belongs to God the moon belongs
to God God the human being belongs to
God the snake belongs to God so the
major
difference between the Hindus and the
Muslims is the common Hindu say
everything is God we Muslims say
everything is gods g o d with an
apostrophe s the major difference is the
apostrophe if we can solve this
difference of apostrophe the Hindus and
the Muslims will be
United how do you do it as the Quran
says
to Comm in terms as in us and you which
is the first
term that we worship none but one Allah
subhana
tala so let's try and understand what is
the concept of God in Hinduism according
to the Hindu Sacred
Scriptures among the Hindu Sacred
Scriptures one of the Sacred Scriptures
are called as
upanishads it's mentioned in the
chandad chapter number six section
number two verse number
one it's a Sanskrit quotation which
means god is only one without a
second it's mentioned in
thead chapter number six verse number
n Jan which means of that God there are
no
parents no Lords almighty God has got no
father he has got no mother he has got
no
Superior it's mentioned in the sh
chapter number four verse number
19 of that God there is no pratima
pratima in Sanskrit
means an image it means an idol it means
a sculpture it means a photograph it
means a picture it means a painting
So chapter number four verse number 19
says of that God there is no image there
is no Idol there is no statue there is
no photograph there is no painting there
is no picture it's mentioned in the
chapter number four verse number
20 it says that you cannot see the image
of God the eye cannot comprehend
God and amongst the Hindu
scriptures the most widely read
scripture is the bhagwat
Gita this is the bhagat Gita which is
the most popular and most widely read
book among the Hindu
scriptures it's mentioned in the bhagat
Gita chapter number 7 verse number 20
all those whose intelligence has been
stolen by material desires they worship
demig
gods and if you read the commentary of
bhagwat Gita by Swami
pru he mentions the demig God here
refers to false gods as well as Idols so
it says all those whose intelligence has
been stoled my material desires they
worship false gods they worship idols
it's further mentioned in bhagwat Gita
chapter number 10 verse number three
they know me as The Unborn
beginningless and the Supreme Lord of
all the
world and amongst the Hindu scriptures
the most
sacred they are The
Vedas it's mentioned chapter number 32
verse number three
of that God there is no pratima as I
mentioned earlier pratima is a Sanskrit
word which means an image an idol a
statue a painting a picture a photograph
so chapter number 3 to verse number
three
says of that God there is no image there
is no Idol there is no statue there is
no picture there is no painting there is
no
photograph it's mentioned there chapter
number 40 verse number
8 Almighty God is imageless and pure
it's mentioned 40 verse number
9 andhat means Darkness panti means
entering ASI means the natural things
like fire water air Etc so chapter
number 40 verse number 9 says they are
entering Darkness those who worship the
Asti the natural things like fire water
air Etc and the ver continues they are
entering more in darkness those who
worship the Samui those who worship the
created things like Idols chair table
Etc who says that yaj chapter number 40
verse number
9 it's mentioned Atara book number 20
him number 58 Mantra number three da
Mahi verily great is almighty God and
amongst the
Wes the most secred is the
r it's mentioned r book number one him
number
164 Mantra number
46 truth is one God is one SES and
Saints call him by a variety of names
and the same message repeated in r book
number 10 him number 114 Mantra number
five that sages and saintly people call
God by a variety of names and there are
no less than 33 different attributes
given to almighty God in rig book number
two hymn number one
alone one amongst them is mentioned in
rig book number two himn number one
Manta number three as
Brahma Brahma is
called as the
Creator if you
translate into Arabic it means khik we
Muslims have got no objection if someone
calls almighty God as khik or the
Creator but if someone says Brahma is
almighty God who has got four heads and
on each head is a crown you're giving an
image to almighty God and you are going
against satar upanishad chapter number
four verse number 19 which
says of that God there is no
image the other attribute given to
almighty God r book number two himn
number one man number three is Vishnu
Vishnu is called as the sustainer the
cherisher if you translate into Arabic
it's somewhat similar to R we Muslims
have got no objection if someone calls
almighty God as r or cherisher or
sustainer but if someone says that
Vishnu is almighty God who has got four
hands and one of his right hands he has
the chakra The discus one of his left
hands he has the Conch he's flying on
the bird by the name of Garuda or
reclining on a bed of snakes
we Muslims take strong objection to it
moreover you're giving an image to
almighty God and going against J chapter
number 32 verse number three which
says of that God there is no
image it's further mentioned in r book
number eight him number one Mantra
number
one do not worship anyone but him alone
praise him
alone it's mentioned in r book number
six himn number
45 mon number
16 praise him alone and the Brahma Sutra
of Hinduism is the fundamental Creed of
Hinduism
is there is only one God not a second
not at all not at all not in the least
bit so if if you read the Hindu
scriptures you should understand the
concept of God in
Hinduism let's try and understand the
sism though
Sikhism is not considered one of the
major world religions but has a Jewish
following it is considered as an
offshoot of Hinduism and it was founded
by Guru nanak in the late part of the
15th
century in the land of Pakistan and
Northwestern India called as Punjab the
land of fire rivers and gurunanak
sa he was born in a Hindu chhatria
family that the warrior cast
family and the word sik is derived from
the word FIA which means a
disciple therefore Sikhism is called as
a religion of 10 gurs the first and the
founder is gurun nanak sah and the last
is gurug Goin sah
and the Sacred Book of Sikhism is the
guru Grant sah also known as ADI
Grant every siik has to maintain his
five KS the first K is the K that is the
uncut hair which all the gurus kept the
second K is the Kanga that is a comb to
keep the hair
clean the third K is
Thea that's a metal or a steel bangle
which is used for strength the fourth K
it is the kpan or the dagger which is
used for self-defense and the fifth K is
the katcha or the long underd draws
underwear which is used for agility
every sick according to sism has to
maintain his 5Ks and if you ask any siik
that what is the definition of almighty
God in sism the best reply he can give
you is quote to you the mool Mantra of
sism that the the fundamental Creed of
sism which is there in the first volume
of gurug Gran first chapter first verse
known as japji it says that God is only
one he's called as the
true the Creator who is Free From Fear
and hate the immortal not begotten
self-existent great and
compassionate this is the description of
almighty God in the japu which is the mo
manra of Sikhism and Sikhism is strictly
a monotheistic religion and in the
unmanifest form almighty God in sism is
called
asara and the Manifest form he's called
as Kara and there are various attributes
given to almighty God in sism in the
Sacred Scriptures he is referred to as
akal that is eternal he's called as the
kar the Creator he's referred to as
satanama which is the Holy Name he's
called as sah which means the Lord he's
called as
perar which means the cherisher he's
called Asim the merciful he's called as
kareim the beneficient he's also called
as wah Guru means one true
God Sikhism besides being a monotheistic
religion
it is against
AAR which means it is against almighty
God taking
Incarnation against almighty God
incarnating known as AAR and it is also
against idol
worship gun nanak he was also
influenced by S Kabir and in our school
days we were taught the cets the doas of
s Kabir and one of the famous couet
which I learned in school
was which means during
trouble all the people remember God but
during peace and happiness no one
remembers God the person who remembers
God in times of peace and happiness why
should trouble touch him this is the
same thing which is mentioned in the
Quran in Surah alumur chapter 39
verse
number8 almighty God says when trouble
toucheth
man he prays to almighty God Allah
subhana wa tala and when almighty God
bestow his favors on him he
forgets that he had prayed to almighty
God and he Associates partners with him
so if we read the gurug Gran and the six
scriptures you should understand the
concept of God in
sism let's discuss
the concept of God in Zoran
ISM Zoran
ism is a non-semitic nonic Arian
religion which is also called as
parm and though it has a very small
following less than
130,000 people mostly living in Bombay
the city where I come from but it claims
to be one of the oldest religions it
originated more than 2 and a half
thousand years ago in
Persia and it was
founded by
Zorra and this religion is also called
the religion of fire worshippers or
religion of
meanmy
God in Zoran ism is called as Aura
Mazda Aura means god or Lord Mazda means
wise a maam means wise God or wise Lord
and the Sacred Scriptures of Zoran ISM
or par ISM are the Dasa and the
aesta there are various
descriptions of almighty God given in
the it's mentioned the that almighty God
is one and
only he doesn't have a beginning neither
does he have an end
he has no mother no father no wife or no
son nothing resembles
him almighty God has got no
images you cannot see almighty God with
your eyes neither can you comprehend him
he's far beyond your understanding and
he's closer to you than your own self
all these descriptions are given in the
sa the sacred scripture of
pares if you read the
the yna and the other books there are
various attributes given to almighty God
he's referred to as the Creator in yasna
chapter number 31 verse number 7 and 11
as well as yasna chapter number 44 verse
number 7 yna chapter number 50 verse
number 11 as well as yna chapter number
51 verse number 7 he's called as the
greatest in yasna chapter number 33 ver
number 11 as well as yna chapter number
45 verse number 6 he's called as the
benefici in yasna chapter number 33:
number 11 as well as yasna chter number
48: number
3 almighty God in the Pari scripture is
also called as the Bountiful in yna
chapter number 43 Verse number 4 5 7 9
11 13 15 as well as yna chapter number
44 vers number number 2 in yna chapter
number 45 ver number 5 in yna chapter 46
ver number 9 as well as yna chapter
number 48 ver number 3 there are various
attributes given to almighty God in the
par scriptures so if you read the par
scriptures you should understand the
concept of God in parm and
zanis let's discuss the concept of God
in Semitic
religions as I mentioned the major among
thetic religions are Judaism
Christianity and Islam first we'll
discuss the concept of of God in
Judaism it's mentioned in the Old
Testament in the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number six verse number four
Moses peace be upon Him says in
Hebrew it's a Hebrew quotation which
means your Israel the Lord our God is
one
Lord It's mentioned in the book of
Isaiah chapter number 43 Verse number 11
I even I Am Lord and there is no savior
besides
me it's mentioned in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 45 verse number 5 I Am
Lord and there's none else there is no
God besides
me it's mentioned the book of Isaiah
chapter number 46 verse number 9 I am
God and there's none like
me it's further mentioned in the book of
Exodus chapter number 20 verses 3 to 5
it says Thou shal have no other gods
besides me there almighty God speaking
in the Old Testament book of Exodus
chapter number 20: 3 to 5 thou shal have
no other God besides me Thou shalt not
make unto thee any Graven image of
anything of any likeness in the heaven
above in the earth beneath and the water
under the Earth Thou shalt not bow down
to them nor serve them for I thy God thy
Lord am a jealous
God a similar message is repeated in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 5
verse number 7 n which says Thou shalt
have none other gods besides me Thou
shalt not make unto thee any Graven
image of anything of any likeness in the
heaven above in the earth beneath and
the water beneath the Earth thou shall
not bow down to them nor serve them for
I thy God thy Lord am a jealous God so
if you read the Jewish scriptures the
Old Testament you should understand the
concept of God in Judaism that you have
to believe in one God and almighty God
has got no images
before we discuss the concept of God in
Christianity I would like to make a few
points
clear Islam is the only non-Christian
Faith which makes it an Article of Faith
to believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him no muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him we
believe that he was one of the mightiest
messengers of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of
almighty God we believe that he was the
Messiah translated Christ we believe
that he was born miraculously without
any male Intervention which many modern
day Christians today do not believe we
believe that he gave life to the Dead
with God's permission we believe that he
healed those born blind and lepers with
God's permission the Christians and the
Muslims we are going together but one
may ask then where is the paring of ways
the paring of ways is that there are
many Christians who say that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him he claimed
Divinity in fact if you read the Bible
there is not a single unequivocal
statement in the complete Bible where
Jesus Christ peace be upon him himself
says that I am God says worship
me i' would like to repeat the
statement there is not a single
unequivocal statement not a single
unambiguous statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
him himself says that I am God or he
says worship me if any Christian can
point out any unequivocal statement any
unambiguous statement from anywhere in
the Bible where Jesus Christ peace be
upon himself says that I am God or where
he says worship me I'm ready to accept
Christianity
today I'm not speaking on behalf of my
other Muslims I'm a student of
comparative religion
I'm ready to put my head on the
guillotine if any Christian can point
out any single unequal statement in the
complete Bible where Jesus Christ peace
be upon himself says that I am God or
where he says worship me I am ready to
accept Christianity in fact if you read
the Bible Jesus Christ peace be upon him
he mentioned himself in the Gospel of
John chapter number 14 verse number 28
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said my
father is gter than I Gospel of John
chapter number 10 verse number 29 my
father is gter than
Gospel of Matthew number 12 verse 28 I
cast out Devils with the spirit of God
Gospel of Luke number 11 verse number 20
I with the Finger of God cast out devil
Gospel of John chapter number 5 verse
number 30 I can of my own self do
nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of almighty God anyone who
says I seek not my will but the will of
almighty God he's a Muslim Jesus Christ
peace be upon him as a Muslim he never
claimed divinity in fact he clearly
mentioned it's mentioned in the gospel
of Matthew chapter number 5 verse number
7 to2 Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said that think not that I am come to
destroy the law of the prophets I have
come not to destroy but to fulfill until
the heavens and the Earth pass away not
one jot or title shall pass away from
the law until all be fulfilled and
whosoever shall break one of the least
Commandments and teach men to do so
shall be called least in the kingdom of
heaven and whosoever shall keep the
Commandments and teach men the same they
shall be called great in the Kingdom of
Heaven unless your righteousness exceeds
the righteousness of the scribes and the
Pharisees in no way shall you enter the
Kingdom of Heaven this is a verbum
quotation from the gospel of Matthew
chapter number 5 verse number 17 to
20 and you can check it up Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said that if you want
to enter
Jenna you have to be better better than
the Jews better than the scribes and the
Pharisees you have to follow each and
every commandment of Moses peace be upon
him even if you break one of the least
Commandments you shall not enter Jenna
you shall not enter Paradise they have
to believe in everything what Moses
peace be upon him said earlier you have
to believe in one God that God has got
no images
Etc Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
never claimed Divinity in fact he said
it's mentioned in the Gospel of John
chapter number 14 verse number 24 Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said that the
words that you he are not mine but my
father's who has sent me it's mentioned
in the Gospel of John chapter number 17
verse number three this is life eternal
so that you may know there is one God
and Jesus Christ whom thou has
sent it's further mentioned in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 19
verse number 16 and 17 once a person he
approaches Jesus Christ peace be upon
him and he asked him that good Master
what good things should I do so that I
shall receive eternal life he's asking
Jesus Christ peace be upon good Master
what good things should I do so that I
will get eternal life I shall go to
paradise so Jesus Christ peace be upon
Him replies and says why thou callest me
good leave as said God why thou callest
me good there's only one good and that
is almighty God and if thou want to
enter eternal life if you want to enter
Paradise you keep the Commandments Jesus
Christ peace be upon did not say that if
you want to enter Paradise believe that
I am God he did not say believe that I
died on the cross for your sins he said
if you want to enter Paradise you keep
the Commandments all that there is one
God God has got no images
Etc it's clearly mentioned the book of
Acts chapter number two verse number 22
it says e men of Israel listen to this
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of God
amongst you by Miracles and wonders and
signs which God did by him and you are
witness to it Jesus of Nazareth a
man approved of God amongst You by
Miracles and wonders and signs which God
did by him and you witness to it and
when Jesus Christ peace be upon us asked
that which is the first of The
Commandments he replies in the gospel of
Mark chapter number 12 verse number 29
exactly verbi him what was said ear
earlier by Moses peace be upon him in
the book of Deuteronomy chapter number 6
verse number four and he
says it's a Hebrew quotation which means
y Israel the Lord our God is one Lord so
if you read the Christian Bible you
should understand the concept of God in
Christianity that almighty God is only
one has got no images and you have to
worship him alone and no one
else let's discuss the concept of God in
Islam
and the best
reply that any Muslim can give you
regarding the concept of God in Islam is
quote to
youah chapter number 112 verse number 1
to 4 which
says say he's Allah one and only Allah
Allah the absolute and
eternal he begets not nor is he
begotten there is nothing like him
this is a forline definition of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala of almighty God given
in the Glorious Quran if any person says
that so and so entity is God if that
entity fits in this forline definition
we Muslims have got no objection in
accepting that person as God the first
is say he Allah one and only Allah Allah
the absolute and eternal Samad cannot be
described in the English language it
means a person who is self-existing he's
Eternal he's absolute everything is
dependent on him he's independent of
anything and everything it has a very
broad
meaning he begs not know he
begotten there is nothing like unto him
this class is the Touchstone of
theology theology means it comes from
the Greek word Theo meaning God logic
means study theology means study of God
and Touchstone means if you want to buy
gold or to sell gold you normally go to
a Goldsmith and you want to find out how
pure that gold is so if you want to buy
gold you go to a Goldsmith he takes the
gold and he rubs it against the touch
Stone and he matches the color
with the card he has got and then he
tells you whether the gold is 24 karat
gold or 22 karat gold or 18 karat or it
may not be gold at all because
Everything That Glitters Is Not
Gold and that panel is also there in the
exhibition surlas the Touchstone of
theology so
anyone who says that so and so person is
God you put him to the test of surlas if
he passes the test we Muslims have got
no objection in accepting that person is
almighty God for example there are many
human beings who say that bhagan rashish
he's almighty
God once didn't question answer time
there was a Hindu brother who told me
brother Zak we don't believe bhagan does
need to be God and I told him I never
said that the Hindus believe bhagan to
be God I said some people many people
believe bhagan need to be God I've read
the Hindu scriptures no way do the Hindu
scriptures say that bhagan rajnish is
god let's put this bhagan rajnish to the
test of suras the first
is say he is Allah one and
only was rajish one and only was he the
only human being who has claimed to be
God there are many hundreds and in this
country of us in India there are
thousands of men who have claimed to be
God
but a rajnish b will say no he is
unique let's go to the next
test Allah Allah the
absolute and eternal was rajish absolute
and eternal when you read his
autobiography it's mentioned in the
autobiography of rajnish that he was
suffering from diabetes mtis from asema
from chronic back achee imagine almighty
God suffering from diabetes Mal
from asema from chronic
backache and the third test
is he begs not no he begotten we know
that bhan Rish he was born in the state
of mad Pradesh and he had a mother and
father and in the year 1981 he goes to
America he goes to USA and he takes
thousands of Americans for a ride and in
the state of Oregon he starts his own
village which was called as rajnish
puram later on the American government
they arrest bhagan rajnish and they put
him behind bars in prison and bhagan
Rish says that the American government
gave me slow poisoning imagine almighty
God being slow
poisoned and in
1985 the American government kick bhagan
rashish out of USA and he comes back to
India and goes back to the city of Puna
in Maharashtra the state where I come
from and he goes back to his old Center
and gives it a name the Osho
commune and if you go to the Osho
commune and I've been there several
times it's mentioned on his
sadii bhagan rashish
ohho never born never died but visited
the Earth from the 11th of December 1931
to the 19th of January 1990
never born never died but visited the
Earth from the 11th of December 1931 to
the 19th of January 1990 they forgot to
mention in his samadi that he was not
given visas to 21 different countries of
the World Imagine almighty God coming
down to this earth he wants to visit the
world and he requires visas he was not
given visas to 21 different countries of
the world and the Arch Bishop of Greece
said if you don't remove rajnish out of
this country we will burn his house and
the house of his
disciples and the last
test there nothing like him is so
stringent that no one besides the true
almighty God can pass the moment you can
compare God to anything in this world
he's not
God and we know rajish like us human
beings he had two eyes one nose two
hands white beard he wore a white robe
the moment you can compare God to
anything in this world he's not God
not they're nothing like him for example
if someone says almighty God is thousand
times stronger than Arnold swasher you
might have heard the name Arnold swasher
the person who got the title Mr world
the strongest man in the world Mr
Universe the strongest man in the
universe if someone says almighty God is
thousand times stronger than an fer the
moment you can compare God to anyone
whether it be and figer whether it be D
Singh whe whether it be King Kong
whether it be a thousand times or
million times the moment you can compare
God to anything in this world he's not
God there nothing like him this is a
four-line definition which is given in
the Quran in surlas chapter number 112
verse number 1 to 4 that anyone who you
claim to be almighty God if he fits in
this forline definition we Muslims have
got no objection in accepting that
person as almighty God so whichever God
you're worshiping I i' like to tell the
audience here and all my brothers as
well as my sisters that whichever God
you're worshiping put him to the test of
surlas if that God passes the test of
surlas he is a true God if he does not
pass the test of Surah class he is not a
true
God and we
Muslims we prefer calling Allah subhana
tala by the Arabic word Allah instead of
the English word God people ask the
question why do you call call him Allah
the reason we call Allah by the Arabic
word Allah instead of the English word
God is because a person can play
Mischief with the English word God for
example if you add s to God it becomes
God's P of God there nothing like P
Allah say is Allah one and
only if you add DS to God it becomes
goddess meaning a female god there
nothing like male Allah or female Allah
Allah subhana tala is unique he has got
no gender the moment you add father to
God it becomes Godfather he's my
godfather he's my guardian there's
nothing like Allah father or Allah ABA
in Islam if you add mother to God it
becomes god mother there nothing like
Allah mother or Allah am in Islam Allah
is a unique word if you prefix a 10
before God it becomes tin God meaning a
fake God there's nothing like tin Allah
and Islam that the reason we Muslim
Muslims we prefer calling Allah by the
Arabic word Allah instead of the English
word God but when the Muslims are
speaking to non-muslims who may not
understand the concept of Allah and when
they use this word god instead of Allah
I've got no objection but I would like
to remind them that God is not the
appropriate translation of the Arabic
word
Allah but when we speak to non-muslim
and you use this word I've got no
objection there are many
non-muslims who come and ask
me God can do anything and everything so
why do you have a problem if God becomes
a human
being God can do anything and everything
so what's your problem if he becomes a
human being I said fine if I agree with
you for sake of argument that God can do
anything and everything and if God can
become a human being if God becomes a
human being he sees it to be God because
the qualities of God and human beings
they opposite almighty God is Immortal
human being is Mortal you can't have a
person who's Immortal and Mortal at the
same time you can either have an
immortal person or a mortal person you
can't have an immortal mortal person it
is
[Music]
meaningless almighty God he has got no
beginning human beings have a beginning
you can't have a God man a person having
a beginning and no beginning at the same
time it is meaningless almighty God has
got no end human me have an end you
can't have a person who has an end and
no end at the same time it is
meaningless it's like me telling you I
saw a tall short man I can either see a
tall man or a short man I can see a
medium man I can't see a tall short man
it's
meaningless I can't see a fat thin man I
can either see a fat man or a thin man
or a medium man but not a fat thin man
therefore if you say allmighty God
became a human being then he seizes to
be almighty God if he Almighty Mighty
God can do anything and everything human
beings we require to eat almighty God
does not require to eat Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Anam chapter number 6
verse number 14 he feeded everyone but
does not require to be
fed almighty God does not require to
eat we human
beings we require sleep we require rest
almighty God does not require sleep and
rest it's mentioned in the
Quran number 2 verse number 25
he's Allah one and only absolute the
Eternal no Slumber can seize him nor
does he require rest to him belongs
everything in the heavens and the
Earth therefore if you
agree with this argument that almighty
God can do anything and everything and
if almighty God becomes the human being
you have to agree that he sees to be God
so if a person who sees to be God and
becom the human being like you and me
then why should I worship a human being
like you and me it does not make sense
and if some people say again that human
being became God if human being can
become God even you and I can become God
so where's the question of human being
becoming God so therefore this
argument that God can do anything and
everything if you go a step further if
God can do anything and
everything God can even tell a lie
but to tell a lie is ungodly the moment
God tells a lie he sees it to be God in
the same argument almighty
God if he wants he can do Injustice but
it is ungodly to do Injustice Allah says
in Surah n 4 ver number 40 Allah subhah
wa ta'ala is never unjust in the least
degree the moment God does injustice he
sees it to be
God in the same argument if God can do
anything and everything almighty God if
he wants he can
forget but to forget is ungodly Allah
says in Surah chapter number 20:52 Allah
subhah wa ta'ala never forgets the
moment almighty God forgets then he e
this to be God if you agree with the
same argument God can do anything and
everything almighty God can make a
mistake but to make a mistake is ungodly
Allah says in the Quran in Surah 20:52
Allah subhana tala never s he never
makes a mistake the moment almighty God
makes a mistake it's e to be God
therefore if you read the Quran nowhere
does the Quran say Allah can do anything
and everything what does the Quran
says verily Allah has power over all
things it's mentioned several plac in
the Quran in Surah Bak chapter number 2
vers 106 Surah Bak chapter number 2 vers
number 109 Surah Bak chapter number 2
vers number 284 in Surah Al Imran
chapter number 3: 29 in chapter number
16: 77 in Surah f chapter number verse
number one Allah
says for
verily Allah has power over all things
and Allah says in Surah B chapter number
85 verse number 16 that Allah is the
doer of all the intents whatever he
intends he can do but he does not intend
doing ungodly things like telling a lie
like making a mistake like forgetting
like doing Injustice like becoming a
human
being the Quran says
for verily Allah has power over all
things Allah can do whatever he intends
but does not intend doing ungodly things
like making a mistake like forgetting
like doing Injustice like becoming a
human being that's the reason almighty
God will not become a human being and
the Quran clearly mentions in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number
18 the deaf the dumb the blind they will
not return to the true part a similar
message repeated in the Bible in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 13
verse number
13 they see yet they see not hearing
they hear not neither do they understand
the same message repeated in r book
number 10 him number 71 Mantra number
four they see the word yet they see not
some people hear the word yet they are
not all these scriptures the Quran the
Bible the vi they are saying seeing the
see not hearing they hear not neither do
they understand they are telling clearly
that the scriptures are explicitly in
clear terms mentioning that almighty God
is one he has got no images worship him
alone yet there are
people the deaf the dumb the blind they
will not come to the true part hearing
they hear not neither do they understand
r book number 10 himn number 71 verse
number four that some see the word yet
they see not others hear the word yet
they hear not all these scriptures are
saying that the definition of almighty
God is given so explicitly in the major
world religions yet people behave like
blind people like deaf people and do not
follow the
scriptures and most of the major
religions except Islam they have a
philosophy known as anthropomorphism
that almighty God he takes the form of a
human being he becomes a human being it
is known as anthropomorphism except
Islam most of the major religions
believe that almighty God became a human
being once some believe he became a
human being many times and when you ask
these people they have a very good logic
that almighty God he's so pure he's so
holy he does not know the shortcomings
of the human beings he does not know the
difficulties of the human being he's so
pure he does not know the feelings of
the human beings so almighty God so pure
so Pious so holy he became a human being
and he came in this world to know what
is good or what is bad for the human
being so that he could set the rules for
the human being you know allmighty God
so pure so holy so Pious he does not
know the difficulties of human beings
the shortcomings of the human beings the
feelings of the human beings so he
became a human being to set the rules
for the human being that do and don't on
the face of it it sounds like a very
good logic but I tell these people that
suppose I manufacture a tape
recorder I create a tape recorder do I
have to become a tape recorder to know
what is good or what is bad for the tape
recorder I write an instruction
manual that if you want to play the
audio cassette insert the audio cassette
and press the play button if you want to
fast forward press the FF button if you
want to stop press the stop button don't
drop it from behind it will get damaged
don't immerse it in water it will get
spoiled I write an instruction manual I
don't have to become a tape recorder to
know what is good or what is bad for the
tape recorder because I am the creator
of the tape recorder similarly An
Almighty God he is the creator of the
human beings he does not have to become
a human being to know what is good or
what is bad for the human being what
does he do he reveals the instruction
manual and the last and Fin final
instruction manual for the human beings
it is the Quran the Glorious Quran is
the last and final instruction manual
revealed by almighty God to the human
beings the dos and don'ts of the human
being is mentioned in the Quran almighty
God does not have to become a human
being what does he do he reveals the
instruction
manual and he chooses a man amongst men
and he communicates with them on a
higher level who we call as Messengers
or prophets of God he does not have to
come down on this Earth and become a
human being to know what is good or what
is bad for human being he's the Creator
he reveals the instruction manual and
the last and fin instruction manual is
the Glorious
Quran the Quran says in Surah chapter
number 17 verse number
110 say call upon Him by Allah by
whichever name you call upon him to him
belongs the most beautiful
name you can call Allah subhana wa tala
by any name but it should be a beautiful
name it should be a name given by Allah
subhana wa ta'ala it should not conjure
up a mental picture and there are no
less than 99 different attributes given
to Allah subhana wa tala in the Quran
Alman Alim Alim most merciful most
benevolent most wise no less than 99 and
the grounding one is Allah and this
wasse to Allah belongs the most
beautiful name besides Surah is chapter
number 17 verse number 110 is also
mentioned Surah CH number 7 vers number
980 and Surah T CH number 20 verse
number 8 as well as Surah alash 59 ver
number 24 to Allah belong the most
beautiful
names and there are certain criteria as
far as the name and attributes of Allah
are concerned it should be a name given
by himself and besides that it should be
a unique name for example most of us
know that the first man who said foot on
the moon he was Neil
Armstrong now if I have to give an
attribute to Neil Armstrong and if I say
that Neil Armstrong is an
astronaut yes Neil Armstrong is an
astronaut but it's not unique there are
thousands of astronaut if you reverse it
who's an astronaut the answer will not
be Neil Armstrong it can be a thousand
people if I say Neil Armstrong is an
American there are millions of people
American who who an American you can
give a million names it's not unique
belonging to Neil Armstrong alone so if
I have to give a unique attribute to
Neil Armstrong I have to say Neil
Armstrong is the first man who set foot
on the moon if you reverse it who's the
first man who set foot on the moon the
reply is Neil
Armstrong so similarly when you give an
attribute to almighty God it should be
unique if you say almighty God created a
building who can create a building there
can be a thousand people who can create
a building but if you say he is the
creator or the creator of the universe
who's the creator of the universe Allah
subhana
tala most mul who's the most merciful
answer is only one Allah so the
attribute you give and the name you give
should be unique and belong only to
Allah and no one
else some people may say that why there
should be only one
God why can't there be many
gods if there would have been many gods
surely these Gods would have fought
among themselves and we find this in the
mythology of some of the religions one
God fighting with the other God one God
helping the other God to fight the third
God can you believe in such a God who
can be defeated who can be
killed and some people say that why
can't there be different God one God for
son
one God for cloud one God for wind now
imagine if there was one God for each
each one having power over his own
little thing it's logical to have one
God who has power of all things rather
than each different different God
fighting among themselves it's
illogical that's the reason the Quran
says in Surah Amia chapter number 21
verse number 22 that if there would have
been Gods besides
Allah surely there have been confusion
in the
universe it's mentioned Surah M chapter
number 23 verse number 91 that Allah
subhana does not big a son if there were
God besides
Allah each God would have taken things
would have created and holded on the
other surely they would have been
infighting amongst them that's what we
see in the mythology the best and the
most logical is only one God one and
only all powerful having power over all
things that's the reason if you read the
scripture es of the major world
religions all the scriptures of the
major world religions they say that
almighty God is
one he has got no images he's not
begotten he's one and only absolute
Eternal there nothing like
him and by the passage of time many of
the
scriptures almost all besides the
Quran these scriptures have changed
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number
79 that vote to those who write the book
with their own hands and then say this
is from Allah to traffic with it for a
miserable price vote to those for what
they earn vote to those for what they
write so here it's mentioned in the
Quran that people write the scripture
with their own hands and then say this
is from Allah so by the passage of time
all the scriptures that came before for
the Quran they have been changed and
since they were not the last and final
Revelation almighty God did not think it
fit to be
preserved because those were the
previous Revelations but in spite of
this corruption in spite of the
manipulation in spite of the change yet
in the remnants of all the major world
religions in the scriptures you will
find the mention of monotheism the
Oneness of almighty God that he has has
got no images he's not begotten he's one
and only there's nothing like
him so if you believe in a concept of
God it should be according to your
scriptures there are some religions
which
agnostic you may not call them religions
like Buddhism they don't comment on God
they are silent as far as God is
concerned and many ethical systems which
I mentioned earlier like conf fism TSM
there are more of ethical systems than
having concept of God and as far as the
people are
atheist like jism Etc to those who are
agnostic an atheist they can refer to my
video cassette is the Quran God's word
and I gave that earlier also as well as
recently in bomb a couple of months back
on the 24th of November on the second
day of the peace exhibition in mombay
the solution humanity is the Quran God's
word if they see this cassette or the
talk inshallah if the human being is
unbiased with the help of the Quran I've
proved the existence of Allah subhana wa
tala as far as Islam is concerned Islam
does not merely believe in monotheism
Islam believes
ined toed means
unification it means a certain Oneness
it comes from the root word wah means to
unite to unify it means to consolidate
Islam does not merely believe in
believing in one God it believes ined
and there are three categories
of
and in the first category
of it means maintaining the unity of R
Unity of
lordship is derived from the Arabic word
r meaning Lord sustainer cherisher
meaning
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala is the
creator the cherisher the sustainer of
everything in the
universe everything is dependent on him
and he is independent of anything and
everything maintaining the unity of
lordship of Allah subhana wa tala that's
called
as the second category
is maintaining the unity of the names
and attributes of Allah subhana tala
this is further divided into five
subcategories number one is whatever
name you give to Allah subhana wa ta'ala
it should be the name that he himself
has given him you cannot give your own
names to Allah subhana tala you cannot
say that Allah is
Al the angry one the Quran does say he
gets angry but that's not one of the
names Allah has given himself or the
messenger has given to Allah subhana wa
tala number two when you describe the
attributes of Allah subhana wa taala you
describe it according to how Allah has
described himself or the messenger has
described Allah subhana wa tala you
can't give your own description and
whatever the meaning is you have to take
it you can't give your own description
allegorical meanings to the description
of Allah subhana wa
tala the third is you cannot give the
qualities of the creation of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to Allah himself you
can't say that Allah forgets knows bah
that is the quality of his creation you
cannot say Allah makes a mistake like
some of the scriptures say that God made
a mistake these are the qualities of his
creation number four you cannot give the
attributes and qualities of Allah to any
of his creation you can't say I know a
person who's Immortal who's
Eternal these are the qualities of Allah
subhana tala and the fifth category is
that you cannot give the name of Allah
to any of his creation if you have to
give you have to add AB to it for
example you cannot say that
he's you can say ABD Rim the servant of
the most
merciful and you cannot add anything to
AB except Allah anything besides Allah
you can't say ABD he is the servant of
rasool this is not permitted it breaks
the second category
of and the third category
is maintaining the unity of worship I
comes from the Arabic root word
AB which means to serve meaning a slave
meaning a servant
servitude we have to maintain the unity
of worshiping Allah alone and no one
else means maintaining the unity of
worshiping Allah alone and no one else
if you follow the first two categories
that the saying Allah he is a he's a
sustainer creator also agreeing with
giving him good names and attributes
create Etc but if you worship somebody
else besides Allah then to your breaking
and there are several such examples in
the Quran Allah subhah wa tala in the
Quran in Sur yunus chapter number 10
verse number 31 refers to the pagans of
Makkah refers to the mushriks and he
says that when you ask them that who is
the one who
sustains the things in the heavens and
the Earth who has the power to hear and
see who has the power to give life to
the dead and dead to the life who has
power to regulate all the Affairs they
will say
Allah then why don't you show piety to
him that means Allah is referring to
these Pagan Arabs in
Makkah he's agreeing that they believe
in Allah they called him Allah they gave
good attributes good
names was
there there but they
worshiped things other than
Allah and the similar example is given
in Z Chapter number 43 Verse number 87
that when you ask these
mushriks that who is the one who gave
life to you they will say Allah then why
do you join partners with
him so here we realize that only
following the first two category is not
sufficient following all three
categories of toed simultaneously is
important if you break any one of the
categories
ofed it's called as
shik shik in Islam is the biggest sin
shik in Arabic means associating
Partners in the Islamic terminology it
means associating partners with
Allah it is the biggest sin if you break
any one of the three categories of
you're doing
shik it's the biggest sin in Islam and
Allah says in the Quran inaha chapter
number four verse number 48 Allah
forgiveth
not that you associate partners with him
anything else if he pleases he may
forgive but anyone who associate
partners with him has done the most
Grievous heinous
sin the same message repeated any Isa
chapter number four verse number 116
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does not
forgive the sin of joining Gods with him
anything else if he pleases he may
forgive but anyone who has joined Gods
with Allah he has strayed away too far
according to the Quran the sin which
Allah will never forgive is
shik therefore while doing dawa while
speaking to any human being the best
message you can convey
is convey the message of Allah that we
worship none but
Allah and Allah says in the Quran in
chapter number five verse number 72 it
says
who they are
doing those who say that Allah is Christ
the son of
Mary but said Christ is oh children of
Israel oh
worship
Allah who's my Lord and your
lord anyone who Associates partners with
Allah Allah will make J forbidden for
them Allah will make Paradise forbidden
for
them and fire shall be his dwelling
place and he shall have no helpers in
the Hereafter Jesus Christ peace be upon
him
said anyone who associate partners with
Allah
Allah will make Paradise forbidden for
him and fire shall be his dwelling place
and he shall have no helpers in the
Hereafter that the reason I started my
talk by quoting verse of the Quran from
Surah Al Imran chapter number three
verse number 64 which
says say people of the
book come to come in terms as between us
and you which is the first term
Allah that we worship none but Allah
only believ in one God is not sufficient
besides believing in one God you also
have to worship him alone and no one
else the first term
is that we worship none but Allah one to
almighty
God that weate no partners with
him that we erect not among
ourselves Lords and Pat other than Allah
then they turn back say witness Muslim
we are Muslims bowing our will to Allah
subhana wa tala and Allah says in the
Quran
in chapter number 12 verse number 106
that most of the people do not worship
Allah without associating partners with
him that means most of the people when
they worship Allah they also associate
partners with him
the right thing is worship him without
associating Partners Allah says in Surah
L chapter number 31 verse number 27 that
if all the trees on this Earth was
converted to
pens and all the oceans into ink back
with the seven ocean yet the words of
Allah would not be
exhausted I would like to when my talk
by giving the quotation of the Glorious
Quran from Surah Haj chapter number 22
verse number 73 which says amen listen
list to this Parable all those who you
take for protector besides Allah if all
of them gathered together to create a
fly they cannot even create a fly if all
those who you worship besides Allah even
if they gathered they will not be able
to create a fly and if the fly snatches
away something they will not be even
able to get it back fee are those who
petition fee are those who they petition
alhamdulillah